un nouvel élément du patrimoine limousin
est inscrit officiellement depuis
aujourd'hui à l'inventaire
supplémentaire des monuments historiques
qu'il s'agit du four à porcelaine de
lusine gédéas de limoges
ce four construit en 1884 a cessé de
fonctionner en 1938 il est actuellement
en piteux état comme l'est d'ailleurs
l'édifice qu'il abrite
c'est le premier bâtiment industriel de
la région a figuré sur l'inventaire des
monuments historiques
la chance à plus d'une fois souri aux
vieux four des porcelaines gédé a
plusieurs fois il a échappé la
disparition totale de 1884 1938 il a
cuit sans faillir à sa tâche
dernièrement en 80 il a survécu à un
incendie qui a ravagé l'entreprise
c'était un four à flamme renversé une
petite révolution pour l'époque c'était
ce qu'on appelle un four à flamarens
versé et la cuisse ans faisait au bois
et au charbon uniquement et c'est
consommer beaucoup
ah oui ça consommer énormément oui
plusieurs tonnes de charbon pour chaque
puissant lobby vista four avec plusieurs
étages et ce quel âge avait une
particularité c'est exact c'est un four
qui est à deux étages la première partie
qui est en hausse à plélo de l'homme
là où on fait la première cuisson qui
est à 900 degrés à l'époque c'était du
960 et le rez-de-chaussée qui s'appelle
laboratoire là en cui à 1400 degré et
cite la récupération de la cuisson au
rez-de-chaussée qui faisaient la
température idéale pour le bigourdan
est ce que c'était un système
satisfaisant à l'époque oui ce sont des
faux qui fait très sophistiquée et qui
est parfaitement conçu la clé de son
succès une température intérieure
relativement homogène par la suite il eu
des petits frères rien qu'à j'ai déjà il
faisait partie d'un ensemble de six
fours similaire est de nos jours à
limoges il ne subsistera que carrefour
de ce type où jean reno et happyland ça
a porté une arme si vous voulez dans une
entreprise que l'on n'a pas avec le
matériel moderne maintenant ça c'est
vrai il ya un peu de nostalgie quand on
voit les vieux murs un grand soulagement
puisque c'est avec amertume que je
voyais disparaître ce patrimoine qui il
est même déjà un peu tard pour le sauver
mais enfin c'est une bonne chose qu'il y
ait des gens qui
qui est prise en main et qu'ils
s'occupent activement voilà plus de huit
ans que l'association renaissance du
vieux limoges se battaient pour le faire
inscrire à l'inventaire des monuments
historiques
c'est chose faite désormais l'an dernier
50 mille francs de réparation était
consacrée la toiture du bâtiment
maintenant une autre association de
sauvegarde espace porcelaine espère des
subventions du conseil général et du
ministère de la culture pour la suite
des travaux dans l'entreprise gde juste
en face du vieux four endormi ronfle ses
jeunes collègues
rien à voir avec l'ancien très gourmand
qui dévoraient chaque jour des tonnes de
charbon
c'était la télé poc la chance à plus
d'une fois souri aux vieux four des
porcelaines gédé a plusieurs fois il a
échappé la disparition totale de 1884
1938 il a cuit sans faillir à sa tâche
dernièrement en 80 il a survécu à
l'incendié qui a ravagé l'entreprise
c'était un four à flamme renversé une
petite révolution pour l'époque c'était
ce qu'on appelle un four à flamarens
versé et la cuisse ans faisait au bois
et au charbon uniquement et sa course
avait beaucoup à oui ça consomme
énormément ri plusieurs tonnes de
charbon pour chaque cuisse en wifi staff
ou plusieurs étages et avait une
particularité c'est exact c'est un four
qui est à deux étages la première partie
qui est en hausse à plélo de loeb
là où on fait la première cuisson qui
est à 900 degrés à l'époque c'était du
960 et le rez-de-chaussée qui s'appelle
laboratoire là on cuit à 1400 degré et
cite la récupération de la cuisson au
rez-de-chaussée qui faisaient la
température idéale pour le b bourdy est
ce que c'était un système satisfaisant
à l'époque oui ce sont des faux qui
était très sophistiquée et qui était
parfaitement conçu la clé de son succès
une température intérieure relativement
homogène par la suite il eu des petits
frères rien qu'à j'ai déjà il faisait
partie d'un ensemble de six fours
similaire est de nos jours à limoges il
ne subsistera que quatre fours de ce
type ou usine rennes ou et happyland ça
a porté une arme si vous voulez dans une
entreprise que l'on n'a pas avec le
matériel moderne maintenant ça c'est
vrai il ya un peu de nostalgie quand on
voit les vieux murs quel effet ça vous
fait de savoir ses classes et maintenant
un grand soulagement puisque c'est avec
amertume que je voyais disparaître ce
patrimoine qui il est même déjà un peu
tard pour le sauver mais enfin c'est une
bonne chose qu'il y ait des gens qui est
puissant main et qui s'occupe activement
voilà plus de huit ans que l'association
renaissance du vieux limoges se
battaient pour le faire inscrire à
l'inventaire des monuments historiques
c'est chose faite désormais l'an dernier
50 mille francs de réparation était
consacrée la toiture du bâtiment
maintenant une autre association de
sauvegarde espace porcelaine espère des
subventions du conseil général et du
ministère de la culture pour la suite
des travaux dans l'entreprise gde juste
en face du vieux four endormi ronfle ses
jeunes collègues
rien à voir avec l'ancien très gourmand
qui dévoraient chaque jour des tonnes de
charbon
c'était la vieille époque